on a pu le voir de loin et seulement sur
des écrans de télé alexeï navalni aurait
perdu 40 livres mais passons on l'entend
ici traité vladimir poutine de traître
c'est la russie en otage alors que sa
femme ne l'ya était assise dans la salle
d'audience en cette journée morose qui
marque le début de la fin de la
puissante machine que navale n'est
abattu au fusil
car au même homme son numéro deux ah non
c'est bien malgré lui la fin des
opérations de la fondation navales
menées dans toute la russie ue ce
colloque doit chocobo noyau ball senior
pour faire court les bureaux de campagne
existe plus d'ironie de volkov dans
cette vidéo
l'organisation qui sera sous peu de
désigner extrémistes donc illégale au
pays va au-devant des coûts et ferme ses
35 bureaux un démantèlement forcé est un
acte d'exécutions politiques dit il
à cinq mois des élections régionales
leurs comptes bancaires ont aussi été
gelés c'est tolérance zéro
toutes personnes qui travaillent de près
ou loin sous la bannière navale ne
s'exposera à des peines de prison
pouvant aller jusqu'à 6 ans le tableau
s'assombrit de jour en jour pour nous
aussi d'yvan colonna comme éditeur en
chef de mes 12 la plus importante agence
médiatique indépendante qui publie en
russie a été désignée quand l agent
étranger
il n'a plus d'argent pour opérer bcc
comme signé notre arrêt de mort dit il
les revenus publicitaires ont disparu et
plus personne qui pense de façon
indépendante n'est à l'abri de la
répression dit natalia via guina
d'amnesty international en pointant les
caméras de surveillance dans la police
s'est servi pour mener des descentes
chez plus de 100 personnes comme celle
ci qui ont manifesté la semaine
l'année 2000 21 s'annonce comme celle où
il sera presque impossible de manifester
toute dissidence en russie même dans sa
plus simple expression
cette murale apparu lundi à saint
pétersbourg n'y était plus quelques
heures plus tard l'artiste est recherché
pour vandalisme politique ici camara
altéré storage au canada